joining me now is talk radio's royals
correspondent rupert bell uh princess
diana's friend sally morgan who worked
with her for nearly five years in the
90s and lawyer
paula rhone adrian ladies and rupert uh
welcome sally can i start with you
um i found it really strange i live in
windsor i went up to the castle today to
just gauge opinion and i almost found
this generational
reaction if i'm honest the older
generation
called a beautiful wonderful
inspirational and caring
and have no time for meghan markle the
younger generation would say to me we
don't really know too much except for
what we've watched on the crown but we
feel sorry for megan
who was diana the woman that you knew
what made her so special in your mind
well i think that she was um she and she
turned out to be very outspoken
she
uh she was
one of the first people to
talk about her mental health and mental
health she was one of the first
prominent people to embrace individuals
with aids
she was somebody that stood up for the
underdog and i also think that people
could see
her pain
i certainly could see it and i saw it on
a daily basis was she inspirational i
think she was i mean she was inspiration
for so many people for for so many women
at that time that were having
difficulties in their marriage in their
relationships you know if the princess
of wales can divorce the prince of wales
if that can happen then i can certainly
leave my husband who isn't treating me
too well or is having an affair so i
think that she was an inspiration to
many people um paula to bring you in um
meghan markle has by anybody's standards
um
caused so much reaction and let's be
honest a lot of it negative you could
feel that today on the streets you read
it almost every day i think she's caused
a negative reaction i do think
that the press have reacted negatively
my problem my problem with that and i
said it last night and the reason we're
doing it is because it is it is
everywhere it's what people want to talk
about here's what i'm going to say and
i'll say it again if you don't want to
be in the royal family
because you don't want the press
exposure and you don't like every facet
of your life being
interrogated i get that you go to
california with the love of your life
and you have two children you don't land
and sign a deal with spotify and this is
the bit that really gets on my bits if
i'm being completely honest every single
time there is something that matters to
the royal family like the death of
prince philip like you know today the
25th anniversary what does old meghan
markle do drop her latest truth bomb
it's a podcast it's true her timing is
dreadful paulo yeah i know i think it is
i think that oh you know listen
this is what happens the negativity just
runs right what's the fact i'm going to
say a negative i'm going to jump on the
bandwagon and say a negative when we
talk about facts i think what we're
missing here is a reality
you described diana so beautifully and i
would say that i could describe megan in
exactly the same way well we could
describe i could describe megan in that
way but if you look at what she's done
to the royal family it's not what she's
done to the royal family unless she
remembers she don't think she's i don't
i don't know her what i do know is that
the message the very clear message that
we are getting reported to us is that
she's a bully that she's aggressive that
she's taken over harry's life as if he's
some weak individual and yet we forget
that his own mother was forced to flee
this country she herself was planning to
move to la she herself had decided to
begin a relationship with somebody who
didn't look like her who didn't talk
like her who didn't come from a family
that fit into the establishment and this
is what you're asking of megan she
wasn't prepared for this and neither
were the establishment the establishment
got it wrong with diana they got it
wrong with andrew
let me let me bring in let me bring in
let me bring in let me bring in rupert
bell if i can talk to his royal
correspondent he shared a god daughter
with diana and knows through his family
his brother trains for the queen many
links cold stream guards as well rupert
you're very you know you you always play
it very straight down the line what did
you respect what was your response to
what i said about meghan markle like her
or loather it seems to me that she drops
this stuff at the exact moment to cause
as much embarrassment and hurt to the
royal family as possible
it does all her timing is horrendous and
but she has created this we when we went
to the wedding the groundswell of public
opinion was so much in her favor
and yet she has managed and to end up
basically painting this picture that
everything is everybody else's fault
it's never her fault
and i think that's part of the problem
it always seems to saying that
ex-member of the royal family has done
this that member of the reform role has
done that she has not done anything
wrong and i think that's what's
frustrating people why does she always
feel the need to pay the victim as she
sits in her 14 million dollar villa in
in california when most of us can't you
know worried about whether they're going
to get food on the table so i really do
think she needs to start reading the
room and realize that what she is saying
most of the time doesn't
resonate with most of the british public
paula that's quite an interesting point
of rupert's how would you respond to
that quite easily we talk about its
groundswell as if we can dictate what
others think i don't know what the
society thinks because it's not being
reported what i'm being told is that
that's what people think but your own
report has just informed us that
actually there's a lot of people out
there who have sympathy for yeah
absolutely and i said i suspect i
started by saying it was generational i
genuinely believe that absolutely um and
i wonder if it's because of where people
are getting their information from and
if it is generational which i think is
probably right um there is the younger
generation that get their information
get their news from other places
absolutely the older generation who get
their news from different places and who
trust where they get their news i'm not
doubting that but you haven't answered
the question and a supporter of fear
hagen of her last night also did not
answer the question do you not think
there is something in the fact in my
opinion there is we're all entitled
opinion that every time prince philip
died today is the 25th anniversary of
diana the queen is ill she keeps
dropping this stuff via third and fourth
parties there's got to be i'm not saying
she might have a case i'm not saying it
wasn't hard i'm not saying that there
have been people who have said and done
things massively unfair to her i
absolutely can see the comparisons but i
absolutely when i look at those pictures
of the two of them in the uh the diana
picture in the black polar neck and her
as well diana looks vulnerable lost
scared meghan markle looks straight down
the camera and looks like i've got this
absolutely licked i don't she she
doesn't create sympathy in me that's the
problem and and let me tell you why
because let me answer the question
because you answered the question
yourself but your tone was very quiet
when you did i noticed that you said
that the bombs are dropped by some third
or fourth party person omar schmidt or
something we're not suggesting are we
that this is megan that is putting out
this information well we know that it is
megan that wants that from
and then secondly even if she did deny
it where are we going to read that why
do you forget
are you with me on this there's a whole
bizarre article that came out in and i
think it was 2021 forgive me if i've got
the date wrong where it referenced in
very in lots of detail about the
approach that is taken in relation to
megan as opposed to the approach that is
taken to lovely is that because of the
color of her skin seriously i don't know
you tell me i'm interested in what you
say to that i mean she will tell you yes
archetypes yesterday you heard the
podcast she said that she felt that she
was treated as a as a black woman only
when she married a prince um and that's
of course in any way if that's right
that's fundamentally wrong i've said
that from day one i just can't sally get
away from i'm just being honest i can't
see rupert makes a really really good
point
how does that look and sound right now
with this country on the precipice of
economic disaster absolutely but i do
think that when you look at megan and
you look at how she is the one that
really is controlling harry there's
absolutely no doubt she is i mean no she
is paula terry she was versatile
and utterly in love with her when you
really really love someone you will do
anything for them she recognizes that
she refused she looked at the system she
refused to bow to
her brother-in-law and her sister-in-law
she could not understand i'll tell you
what i want to bring uncharted i want to
bring rupert back in because i like the
three of you to to answer this next
question rupert
what would diana the people's princess
and let's be honest floored let's be
honest with her ex-husband both used the
media systematically my old man worked
for the queen mother and he said that
everybody after the queen has used the
media what would diana have have said
about megan when i was out about today
at windsor castle half of the people
were saying she had taken her under the
wing she just felt sorry for the other
half was saying she would have been
gutted that her son and her brother and
his brother had split up over this woman
and she had taken action what would you
say
rupert i i think she would have tried to
give megan all the advice and would have
probably been around to actually
explain the pitfalls that are likely to
come her way and realize what joining
the firm is all about
now i don't know whether they were
briefed enough but the dutch
meghan markle has said that she wasn't
briefed which she knew all about it when
you go in and are going to be
a member of the royal family it's pretty
it comes out pretty quickly and i think
that's what she would have done she
would have and she would have had plenty
of experience good bad indifferent
whatever to bring to the table because
remember she came to the royal family as
a 19 year old very inexperienced young
lady a big age gap between her and our
husband whereas megan was a a lady of
the world being an actress been out
there already married before so much
more experienced there was a naivety
about diana in the early stages because
of the way the royal family was at the
time that then changed and she became a
force you know not always a force you
know she was flawed as you referred to
jeremy but she did though still have the
well-being of her children completely at
the center
i agree can i just say that that that
i mean i i actually i'm going to
disagree with you and rupert a little
bit because and i know this from the old
man there is absolutely no preparation
for going into the royal family i and
the reason you're nodding i yeah i don't
care who you are you can give them a
list from a to z yeah i'm sure it's
uncharted absolutely the fact that's not
my point my point is
to me and we will differ but that's
human nature it's a democracy right she
used to stand outside buckingham palace
i'm utterly convinced this was her big
plan i'm utterly convinced she went for
this i'm being completely serious and i
and i j i think what it is i've said
about that picture there's no
vulnerability this she doesn't link with
people in my humble appearance
she's not vulnerable that's the reason
that we're with sorry paul with with
vulnerability genuine vulnerability you
can see it you can see it
it's powerful
who has walked into the establishment i
am telling you whether you can see it on
her face or not we are very used to
walking into situations where we have to
put on us do you think she knew it was
going to be like that absolutely not
absolutely not she would have gone in
there with her rose tinted glasses i'm
going to be a princess and i'm going to
float around and this is going to be
amazing that's how she approached this
and she got a rude awakening and can i
say just to answer the question that
rupert got the opportunity to yeah you
asked what would diana have done yeah
diana would have been living with megan
in l.a no she wouldn't have done that's
where they would no way that's what
diana needed to do and i think we're
forgetting how the press treated diana
um you're never really their friend
jeremy as we were just saying no but
basically i think that she would the
most the priority for diana now would be
that her boys were not a stranger
and if that would have meant that she
would have had to have pretended to try
and in some way counsel megan she would
have you've got to remember also that
diana yes she was naive when she married
the prince of wales but she was
aristocratic she'd been brought up with
yeah
she knew and her sisters who counseled
her knew the system yeah so you never
know until you're in there and as i've
just said to you are never their friends
never ever even aristocratic people even
other royals are never really their
friends there is this they're they're in
a bubble that's why william at the
moment and catherine they're in do you
can i can i just say
and i think it's i think i'm really
pleased that we've spoken like this
because i think it was for me really
interesting to see the reaction today
from people one final question
were you expecting total negativity yep
really good question really good
question and and what shocked me most
was three teenage girls i thought they
were 20 who said well we've seen it on
the crown
which just blew my mind so to speak um
the three of the historical projects
do you think the three of you we'll
start with rupert ladies first do you
think that the british public will ever
take meghan markle to their hearts
as diana undoubtedly flaws and all was
taken yes or no room
not in her present form she's going to
have to learn to
um not always be knocking the
institution that has been around since
1066. the the royal family may be a
flawed institution at times but there's
only one person who matters and that is
the reigning monarch the rest have to do
her bidding and you've got to work
around it and megan needed to learn how
to work around it and cope with the fact
that harry was six in line to the throne
and was in essence an extra to the main
members of the royal family charles and
william they were but bit part players
thank you rupert uh paula final word
i'm a member of the british society and
i accept her to my heart good for you
sally well and we have to accept her
she's married to harry but i think that
the the general public she's she's a
very headstrong
manipulative um she's very manipulative
paul other people would say independent
she's a businesswoman well right so
there's your point and i've run out of
time but did she look about this whole
thing as a business there you are it's a
very interesting point
i can tell you she was in us a divorcer
oh god nobody told me that you could
have told me that a while ago are we
paying her for this right thank you
ladies thank you
you